انس يستخدمون مصطلح الماكرون السياسيه فهل
هناك فكر سياسي مكروني اعتقد ان هذا الامر
مختلف الرئيس مكحون نفسه قال انه يريد ان
يختار قليلا من هنا وهناك ولا نستطيع ان
نقوله هناك عقيده في المكرونيه اما
ديغوريه فهي فكر وتصور في اطار علاقات بين
الناس وتاليا لفرنسا دور على المستوى
الدولي من اجل المساعده على توطيد
الاستقرار والسلام في العالم وحتى لا يكون
هناك استقطاب ثنائي في العالم في السابق
كانت بين الاتحاد السوفيتي والولايات
المتحده واليوم هي بين الولايات المتحده
والصين اذا كان يجب تلا في هذا الاستقطاب
الثنائي الذي يمكن ان يؤدي الى مواجهه
يمكن لفرنسا ان تلعب دورا من خلال تقديم
طريق ثالث لجمع من لا يريدون الاصطفاف الى
جانب الاتحاد السوفيتي سابقا او الصين
حاليا او الولايات المتحده لانهم يودون
الحفاظ على هويتهم وعلى استقلالهم اذا على
المستوى الدولي هذه هي السياسه الديجوليه
وعلى المستوى الداخلي يجب ان تكون كل
السياسه من اجل الانسان لكي تسمح لكل رجل
وامراه ان يتطور ويتقدم لافضل الاحوال هذه
هي فكره المشاركه فعندما يعملوا الناس في
اطار المؤسسات يجب ان نعترف بدورهم هذا
اطار ايديولوجي اذا صح التعبير ولا ارى
هذا الامر في المرحله الراهنه ولكن ما
اراه ايضا ان الديغوليه تسمح بفهم العالم
ولا يزال لديها دور تلعبون من خلال
التكييف المطلوب لان العالم اليوم ليس كما
كان عليه في العام 19
و40 ولا حتى ما كان عليه في العام
1962 ولكن لم تتحول فرنسا شيئا فشيئا من
دوله عظمى الى دوله يصفها البعض الان
بانها على الاقل تسير في الركب الامريكي
كي لا نقول انها تابعه للولايات المتحده
الامريكيه همم
لا اعتقد ذلك الولايات المتحده هي حليفه
لنا وصديقه ولكن علينا ان ندرك ان
الولايات المتحده تحاول دائما تمريره
مصالحها الوطنيه قبل مصالح حلفائها
واصدقائها وفي شكل عامه كل دوله تهديف في
النهايه الى تحقيق مصالحها يجب تاليا ان
يكون هناك حوار حازم ملؤه الثقه مع
الحلفاء والاصدقاء لا اعتقد ان فرنسا تصف
اليوم الولايات المتحده هناك نقاط مشترك
وصداقه ولكن هناك ايضا مواقف قد تكون
مختلفه